imagine teaching a computer to recognize
handwritten digits in traditional
programming defining rules for each
digits appearance is challenging deep
learning simplifies this with a data set
of handwritten digits a neural network
learns the integrate patterns
autonomously this Concepts extends to
diverse applications a well-trained
network can identify objects and images
comprehend spoken language or even play
strategic games like go deep learning's
magic lies in its capacity to generalize
complex patterns from data so we are
going to discuss deep learnings engineer
road map whether you are a beginner or
already have some experience this road
map will guide you through the essential
steps to become a proficient deep
learning engineer if these are the type
of videos you would like to watch then
hit the Subscribe button like and press
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn before that if you're
one of the aspiring deep learning
enthusiasts looking for online training
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elects to switch
career in deep learning by learning from
the experts then try giving a shot to
Simply learns post-graduate program in
Ai and ml in collaboration with per
University and IBM the link in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of program being
offered so let's get started the
popularity of deep learning is steadily
rising and alongside machine learning
possessing deep learning expertise is
crucial to embark on the Journey of
mastering deep learning focus on
developing the following six essential
skills first math skills second
programming skills third data
engineering skills fourth machine
learning knowledge fifth knowledge of DL
algorithms and sixth knowledge of DL
Frameworks now let's take a quick
overview of each step first one is math
skills the initial and fundamental skill
in deep learning is mathematics
specifically in probability and
statistics linear algebra and calculus
this knowledge forms the foundation for
understanding the workings of machine
learning and deep learning algorithms
it's essential to grasp these
mathematical Concepts before delving
into deep learning as a strong
foundation in machine learning is a
prerequisite for Effective deep learning
second one is programming skills so
strong programming skills are essential
to excel in deep learning numerous
programming languages are available
including python r c and Java however
Python and R stand out as the most
valuable or suitable for deep learning
and machine learning as a beginner I
recommend focusing on learning python
then there is data engineering skills
acquiring data wrangling skills is
imperative for delving into deep
learning given its Reliance on vast data
sets Proficiency in handling and
managing such data is crucial data
wrangling skills encompasses data
pre-processing knowledge of database ETL
extraction transform and load all right
so this was about data engineering
skills coming to the next one which is
machine learning concept or machine
learning skills the subsequent vital
skill involves grasping machine learning
algorithms a foundational understanding
of machine learning is crucial to delve
into deep learning Begin by
familiarizing yourself with key
algorithms such as kniv Bas support
Vector machine K nearest neighbor linear
regression logistic regression
decision tree random forest and K means
clustering and many more now coming to
the next one which is deep learning
Frameworks you should have knowledge of
deep learning Frameworks most popular
framework of deep learning is tensor
flow theano skit learn pytorch caras
dl4j so these were the Deep learning
Frameworks all right now coming to the
Deep learning projects upon mastering
essential deep learning skills initiate
hands-on experience with deep learning
projects engaging in these project will
enhance your skills and add valuable
experience to your resume select a
project from this list and dive into
practical implementation first flower
identification second phase detection
third Parkinson disease detection fourth
image classification with CIF 10 data
set fifth one is handwritten digit
recognition all right you can find these
projects on simply learns YouTube
channel all right now coming to the next
topic which is job roles in deep
learning as highlighted earlier deep
learning has gained immense popularity
for its ability to elevate human efforts
and enhance machine performance through
autonomous learning this popularity has
resulted in lucrative and sought after
career options within the field
including roles like deep learning
engineer designing neural network
architectures implementing algorithms
and optimizing models for Cutting Edge
applications with expertise in machine
learning unraveled complex data sets
enabling systems to learn adapt and make
Intelligent Decisions the role emerges
creativity and Technical progress
pushing the boundaries of what machines
can comprehend and accomplish according
to glaso deep learning Engineers earn
$195,000 in us and 10 ls per year in
India all right so this was about deep
learning engineer now coming to the
second one which is AI engineer AI
engineer play a pivotal role in crafting
programming and training intricate
networks of algorithms consisting
artificial intelligence there is
responsibilities involve enabling these
algorithms to emulate human brain
functions this role Demands a
comprehensive skill set encompassing
software development programming data
science and data engineering according
to glass door ml Engineers earn
$140,000 in us and 11 lakhs per year in
India coming to machine learning
engineer the duty of a machine learning
engineer encompasses the creation
construction and deployment of machine
learning models collaborating closely
with data scientists and software
Engineers the they participate in the
development and execution of machine
Learning Systems according to glass door
ml Engineers earn
$150,000 in us and 11 lakhs per year in
India next one is data scientist the
role of a data scientist involves
Gathering scrutinizing and interpreting
extensive data sets leveraging machine
learning algorithms they uncover pattern
and glean insights from the data
utilizing this knowledge to inform
decisions and address challenges
according to glassor data scientists
earn
$145,000 in the United States and 13
lakhs in India per year now coming to
NLP engineer the specific duties may
vary based on the role in sector but as
outlined by freelancer map an NLB
engineer typically engages in tasks such
as designing natural language processing
systems and addressing speech patterns
and AI speech recognition according to
glas Door NLB Engineers earn
$120,000 in the United States and 10
lakhs per year in India so this was
about about the job roles in deep
learning now coming to the future of
deep learning the future of deep
learning holds promise with advancements
in model complexity unsupervised
learning and interdisciplinary
applications increasing computing power
will drive the development of larger
more sophisticated models expanding
their understanding and generative
capabilities ethical considerations and
responsible AI practices will be pivotal
Dynamic and evolving deep learning
future will likely bring transformative
changes to diverse Industries
emphasizing the need for ongoing
curiosity and awareness of emerging
developments the compan is hiring deep
learning Engineers are Apple Amazon
Google Microsoft and many others so with
this we have come to the end of this
video I hope you find this video
informative and exciting if you like
this video give us a thumbs up and share
it with your friends also if you have
any questions about this video please
feel free to ask in the comment section
our team will get back to you as soon as
possible the courses covered in this
video will be provided in the
description do check them out thank you
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including cluding data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here